E aí
e eu sempre gostei de cuidar da casa
sempre desde a minha adolescência
confesso para vocês que quando era mais
nova eu tinha as minhas bagunças no meu
quarto às vezes fazia aquela montanha de
roupas na cadeira mas como eu sempre fui
muito visual sempre gostei de decoração
então a relação que eu tinha com aquela
montanha de roupas na cadeira
atrapalhava totalmente a decoração do
meu quarto também tinha uns objectos
espalhados uma bagunça digamos assim uma
bagunça normal nada muito complexa além
de atrapalhar decoração do meu quarto a
minha mãe ficava no meu pé diariamente
para que eu arrumasse o meu quarto eu
falava assim mãe para de ser chata sabe
mas hoje eu agradeço a ela de tecido
insistente ali porque a gente aprende na
repetição então eu trouxe essa bagagem
junto comigo e o que fez a minha vida se
transformar a minha mãe eu gostava muito
de limpeza então tudo que eu aprendi de
limpeza truques produtos de limpeza Foi
por conta dela o grande amor que ela
tinha com a casa o capricho sabe então
eu lembro muito a minha mãe nesse amor
que ela tinha pela casa o meu pai também
sempre foi muito organizado aprendi
muito muito com ele principalmente
anotar todos os compromissos e ser
pontual ele sempre falava para mim Rafa
é melhor você chegar meia hora antes
esperar no local do que você chegar
atrasado catopelando as coisas quando a
gente é mais nova a gente não entendi
muito isso a gente acha até que é uma
chatice né mas eu falo assim gente que
eu agradeço o meu pai a minha mãe é pela
essa educação por essa organização que
eu levo para minha vida e olha que faz
muito a diferença gente muito muito
mesmo eu parei de trabalhar para me
dedicar à maternidade em 2009 mas o
tempo Alice foi crescendo e eu não sei
Aquela necessidade de voltar para o
mundo dos negócios eu não estava muito
segura de como voltar para esse mundo né
mundo dos negócios um trabalho que me
realizasse foi aí nesse período que eu
descobri a organização e ela transformou
a minha vida e através da organização eu
criei o meu blog em 2012 que é assim a
minha grande paixão eu posso dizer que
no começo foi muito difícil porque eu
não tive um investimento não quis
investir na verdade então que estudo
muito sozinha pessoas Muitas pessoas não
acreditavam no meu trabalho então eu não
tinha muita aprovação das pessoas enfim
então foi muito difícil mas como eu
queria muito criar esse blog para poder
ajudar as pessoas para poder
compartilhar todas as dicas experiências
com a organização eu fiz acontecer
sábado eu varava noite várias noites na
verdade para tentar colocar alguma coisa
nova no meu blog programação que eu Oi
Bia mas sem programação aprende né
porque quando a gente precisa
necessidade a gente aprende o meu primo
me ajudou muito também porque a
jornalista então eu mandava os textos né
porque eu escrevi a E como eu estava bem
longe da escrita Então ele me ajudava na
edição do texto que me ajudou muito
mesmo eu não tinha pretensão nenhuma de
ganhar dinheiro com blog a minha
intenção realmente era ajudar as pessoas
e fazer alguma coisa que me fizesse bem
e que eu pudesse conciliar a Maternidade
Dois Anos depois eu criei o canal no
YouTube porque eu sinto a necessidade de
mostrar as dicas na prática não é muito
mais fácil a gente ver a dica o passo a
passo do que lê as pessoas pediram vídeo
eu fiquei receosa na verdade porque eu
pensava sem Puxa mas aí eu vou fazer
vídeo as pessoas vão deixar de ler os
meus posts mas na verdade foi o
contrário eu sentia também a necessidade
EA dificuldade das pessoas na
organização das suas casas e Elas
assistiram os meus vídeos como uma forma
de incentivo tá Oi Dedéia tá mantenha
casa mais prática mas organizada Eu
lembro que nesse período meu pai me
incentivou muito com o canal no YouTube
com o blog que posso dizer que meu pai
foi uma das poucas pessoas que me
incentivaram sabe a a fazer os vídeos do
blog E aí ele me presenteou com uma
câmera e aí depois que ele me presencial
com uma câmera os meus vídeos deram tipo
uma aí eu comprei iluminação Então os
índios ficaram com uma cara mais bonita
ao status do meu trabalho nessa época
com mais dedicação com mais apoio com
mais incentivo depois disso eu entendi
que o blog era realmente meu trabalho né
os vídeos eu me dedicava em torno de 8
horas diárias aqui exatamente nesse
nesse espaço que é o meu home office
Então eu pensava poxa é meu trabalho eu
pesquiso né eu gravo meus vídeos sozinha
na época então eu me dedicava muito para
fazer acontecer Sabe eu queria algo mais
desafiador foi aí que eu recebi o com a
editora para lançar o livro foi bem no
momento onde eu fechei em ciclo do blog
Tá então não tinha mais aquela
inspiração aquele tesão de escrever eu
tava mais na vibe de gravar os vídeos e
aí pensei Poxa tenho tanto conteúdo no
meu blog que na época são mais de mil
artigos exclusivos e pensei Poxa eu vou
fechar então o ciclo blog eu vou deixar
guardadinho ali até uma hora que eu né
me inspirar novamente e aí eu selecionei
alguns postes os posts mais legais no
meu blog para a gente criar o livro que
foi lançado em 2017 que foi assim o
grande Marco na minha vida porque no
começo lá atrás quando eu ia em
livrarias não tinham muitos livros sobre
organização até tinha mas era um dia
autoras Americanas e ele só de pensar
que anos depois o meu livro estava ali
nas livrarias assim eu não tenho nem
como
mensurar esse sentimento a inexplicável
que é completamente incrível ver o seu
trabalho suado ali o formato de livro e
você encontrar o seu próprio livro na
livraria então foi assim um filho e um
presente de Deus eu posso dizer bom e o
meu pai faleceu em dezembro d2019e e me
deixou um legado ele sempre falava para
mim não pare até se orgulhar de você
essa frase eu levo assim para a minha
vida sabe compartilho com o mundo é uma
lembrança muito linda que eu tenho das
palavras dele hoje o meu canal é o maior
canal de organização do Brasil é uma
responsabilidade muito muito grande e
assim uma felicidade incrível e através
desse trabalho eu consigo mostrar que o
poder da organização não fica somente na
estética dos ambientes vai muito além
disso
transforma a nossa vida de dentro para
fora e eu aprendi muito fazendo terapia
então a terapia me incentivou ó me
ensinou a olhar para dentro né que é um
exercício é isso a gente se olhar para
dentro a gente se conhecer mas a partir
do momento que a gente se conhece a
gente cria propósito na nossa vida e o
meu propósito hoje com a minha vida com
o meu trabalho que é proporcionar mais
tempo para mim para minha família ter
uma vida prática administrar realmente o
tempo para aproveitar a vida porque a
vida realmente é curta a gente não sabe
o que que vai ser amanhã então a gente
tem que aproveitar cada minutinhos E com
o tempo com a organização do tempo a
gente consegue Então esse é o meu grande
propósito é acordar todos os dias e
pensar puxa hoje eu vou mudar alguma
coisa na minha vida hoje eu vou
organizar meu tempo para ganhar mais
tempo para curtir as pessoas que eu amo
a minha família criar um projeto novo lê
um livro em fim fazer qualquer coisa
então a organização proporcionar tudo
isso sabe e transformou realmente a
minha vida e aí é vontade é imensa de
falar para o mundo né inclusive falando
com vocês aqui e é que a organização tem
esse poder e não fica somente na
estética ela muda transforma a vida não
somente a sua maça a vida das pessoas
que convivem com você é muito
maravilhoso sabe então antes de a gente
organizar as gavetinhas da nossa casa a
gente tem que organizado Davi tinhas
aqui dentro e foi assim que eu fiz então
volte e meia e o organismo as minhas
gavetinha se interna porque a nossa casa
reflete muito do que a gente está
passando por dentro sabe então não
adianta a gente organizar nossa casa se
aqui dentro a gente não está organizado
e a partir do momento que a gente se
conhece sabe que a gente tem esse
autoconhecimento a gente tem mais
autoestima para ver as coisas de uma
forma mais leve de entender melhor ter
uma consciência mais na bagunça da nossa
vida a bagunça da nossa casa mas por
isso que é muito importante a gente
cuidar aqui dentro primeiro para depois
organizar fora eu posso dizer para vocês
que eu tenho uma vida muito agitada e é
eu quero organização para eu driblar
filhos escola casa trabalho marido entre
outras tarefas que uma das coisas que eu
coloco como prioridade é me cuidar e
cuidar da minha saúde mental trabalhar
com internet suga muita energia E por
isso a gente precisa estar com a saúde
mental ali toda equilibrada e é muito
difícil a gente encontrar o equilibrio
mas é um exercício diário o meu grande
desafio foi encontrar os gatinhos que
pudessem me desconectar e fica bem então
por exemplo a leitura de um livro
atividades físicas me faz muito bem
estar em contato com a natureza então é
buscar alguma coisa que me traga leveza
e que me traga a felicidade e também que
não fica naquela loucura que é a
internet não mais hoje né que a gente
não para muito muita informação e se a
gente não pisa no freio a ansiedade
chega e é uma bola de neve à nossa vida
realmente pode vir um verdadeiro caos e
uma coisa que fez muita diferença na
minha vida foi eu não me cobrar muito e
delegar tarefas tarefas do meu trabalho
Principalmente eu comecei Fazendo tudo
sozinha a gravar vídeo sozinha editava
os vídeos cuidava da parte comercial
jurídica administrativa era uma loucura
a partir do momento que eu deleguei né
algumas funções para as pessoas para
equipe foi um divisor de águas na minha
vida mudou completamente sabe porque aí
eu fico focada apenas no que eu preciso
fazer né que a criação de conteúdo então
o de negar também é difícil mas é
preciso para crescer a gente precisa de
lidar depois que a gente descobre Quais
são os nossos propósitos a nossa vida
muda completamente é maravilhoso acordar
todos os dias e fazer algo que a gente
realmente ama sabe e quando focamos em
algo que realmente a gente ama fica mais
fácil a a analisar para que isso
realmente aconteça escrever num papel
metas sonhos objetivos isso também
transformou a minha vida esvaziar
realmente a mente e transferir tudo no
papel um aplicativo no celular faz muita
diferença porque a gente consegue
visualizar tudo que a gente tem medos
angústias vitórias
metas sonhos objetivos tudo fica mais
fácil da gente organizar tudo isso te dá
um up para a gente correr atrás de tudo
isso e tirar obviamente do Papel a
conexão entre a organização mental a
organização do corpo a organização do
bolso a organização pessoal e a
organização da casa andam Sempre Juntas
é preciso que haja um equilíbrio em
todas as áreas da nossa vida para que a
gente crie novos hábitos e faça
acontecer não sei você mas eu gostaria
muito que tivesse
um vinho para se apertasse e
transformar-se totalmente a nossa vida
mas infelizmente não tem né o botãozinho
somos nós mesmo é preciso que a gente
deposite energia para fazer acontecer
para a gente sair realmente da zona de
conforto a partir do momento que a gente
sai da zona de conforto a gente tem mais
força para fazer aquilo virar realidade
então a transformação da nossa vida
depende dos novos hábitos que a gente
vai criar para tudo e aí depois vira
rotina fica tudo mais fácil você sente
falta depois que não fez uma determinada
tarefa a organização EA transformação da
nossa vida são novos hábitos se você
quer realmente mudar a sua vida como eu
mudei a minha vida começa a pensar na
organização de uma outra forma eu recebo
muitas histórias lindas dos meus
seguidores
relatando Como que é o organização mudou
realmente a vida pessoas que estavam em
depressão pessoas que já até pensavam
tirar a sua própria vida por conta do
Caos que ela se encontrava problemas de
relacionamento é procrastinação
muitas base muitas histórias e quando
ela chegam até mim dizendo que a
organização
transformou a sua vida elas não falam
que a sua casa ficou mais bonita a
gaveta ficou mais organizada não a sua
vida realmente se transformou com a
organização é por isso que nesse toque
eu estou falando muito da parte não
estética da organização mas como a
organização muda realmente a nossa vida
sabe e esse a gente criar essa
consciência de que a organização é
fundamental em todas as áreas da nossa
vida a gente começa a ter um up para
querer mudar e ter realmente mais
qualidade de vida vale lembrar novamente
que a organização começa a o Centro para
fora é preciso a gente organizar
primeiro nosso eu depois todas as áreas
da nossa vida e claro a nossa casa e o
nosso ambiente de trabalho vida
organizada é você ter muito mais tempo
para aproveitar cada minutinho da sua
vida e melhor com quem você ama eu
espero muito que essa minha história
possa inspirar a sua vida e você ter uma
outra percepção de transformação de vida
através da organização